here's what would happen if you could
build the Death Star you know some quick
math shows that it would cost you about
852 quadrillion dollars to construct the
Death Star and you'll have over 2
million people living and working aboard
it so the total for keeping the Death
Star operational would amount to 7.8
octillion dollars every day you build it
right outside of Earth's atmosphere just
make sure not to accidentally blast our
planet with the super laser
the Third law of motion teaches that
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction
that means if you loaded up the death
star with energy from the Sun and packed
a big enough punch to destroy a planet
well it would
start flying flying in the opposite
direction don't aim the Death Star at
any planets in our solar system instead
use it to destroy any asteroids headed
toward Earth because